Hey traders, it's Mike and in this video
I'll be following up on my order flow
exhaustion entry model. Now this morning
in the S&P's, you know, PPI came out and
we had a nice sell-off right off the
number and then we just sort of hung
around unchanged, unchanged, unchanged
for about the next 30 minutes before we
put in a 10 point rally. Now there's a
few things that were interesting about
this rally that I I did want to point
out and show you the order flow
exhaustion entry model. All right, so
just really quick, you know, this line
here that you see this yellow line right
here, this is unchanged. So after the
number came out, you know, we sold off
back to unchanged and the market was
just sort of hanging around unchanged.
Then we put in this nice rally before
the cash open. We got all the way up
from around 7422 all the way up to 7434
and
what is taking place here? Well, let's
take a look what happened. Right in
here. Now let me just pull this over a
little bit just so you get some context
of what was happening.
What we had happen is
we have this little sort of congestion
area in here. But in this congestion
area this was a congestion before the
market took off, okay? And you can see
here I got red bar, green bar, red bar,
green bar, but the last green bar it's
got this exhaustion print. It trades one
on the very bottom. Now it's got a nice
positive delta of 290, but look what was
happening as we were going sideways. You
have the delta 455 negative, right? So
you got some strong selling in this bar.
It's got three selling imbalances. Okay,
then the next bar is this green candle
here with a negative delta of minus 55.
Then we come right back down to that
same low of the previous bar
with the red candle and it's got a
negative delta of 33.
This green bar you're starting to see
some expansion, you know, prices
starting to move up. We got one,
two,
three, four, five buying imbalances. You
even got a stacked buying imbalance. But
really what the key was was this
exhaustion print here, the one contract,
cuz we were just spending all this time
down in here around these price levels.
You can see it sold 31 into this low of
this bar, 94 here, 39. Now it trades
just one. So you're seeing that
exhaustion, traders aren't interested
anymore in trading below unchanged and
the aggressive buyers come in, obviously
with the two buying imbalances and the
stacked buying imbalance right here. And
then it's off to the races. Okay, and
more importantly, the delta, it's
negative, but it is what? It's
decreasing. It's minus 455, minus 55,
minus 33. And look at this delta here.
It's it's minus 455. So it's a strong
delta. But
what do you expect when you have a
strong delta number? You expect the
market to go lower and it doesn't. It
just sort of trades next bar trades one
tick lower and then it goes back up. And
then this next bar comes in and we're
staying, you know, we're holding that
low. And then you get that exhaustion
here. Now what what do I mean by
exhaustion is
the last seller has sold before the move
up, right? And then you got this green
bar with the aggressive buying taking
place and you can see the market, it
really just ran here all the way up to,
you know, just before the cash open, got
all the way up to 7435.
So there was a nice opportunity here to
catch a move from this area all the way
up. First stop is here where it went
sideways. Um this is about 8:15. And
then next stop was up here, you know, if
you're in a position going into the cash
open, you may just want to lighten it
up. So you could have, you know, you
could have been looking at, you know,
anywhere from around 22 to 23 up here to
31, 32, even up here to 34, 35.
Now yesterday, actually, um you know, I
put out a video yesterday, but I I just
wanted to go back because after I put
out that video, there was an even better
example of
the order flow exhaustion entry model.
Now, let's just scroll back here.
I think it was around noon. Oh, here it
is. So, this red line here is is the low
of the day right here, this red line.
Okay?
This red line here is is is our low of
the day.
But, look what's happening. So, we're
coming down, we're testing this low.
Okay? As we test this low, you know, it
trades, you got this green candle here,
gets within two ticks of the low. This
green candle here gets within one tick
of the low, and then you sort of form
this double bottom one tick off the low,
and off that low
on this last green bar, what do you got?
You got your exhaustion print, the one
contract right here. One.
Okay? So, again, that's telling you you
hit you're testing this low once,
you know, you could even call this
twice, three, four times, and on the
last time
it only trades one contract. So, what's
that telling you? Is is aggressive
sellers just aren't there anymore. Then,
you know, you got this buying and
balance right here, 37. You know, yeah,
it would have been nice to have maybe
one or two more buying and balances come
in in this bar, but then you see another
buying and balance here, another buying
and balance here,
right before the market again takes off
another 10 points. I mean, it's rallying
from this area in here, which is what?
or sorry, 73.66 and a half all the way
up above this is 66 76 up here. So, it's
cleared quick 10 points over what? You
know, from 12:00 to 12:10 right here.
So, it's about 10 minutes. Now, when you
look at Let me just scroll this over a
little bit so you get a better idea of
this move up, right? It got all the way
up
to 39, right? Even then even shot up,
kept going up up up, but again, you
know,
first stop was right up here.
Right right in here, which is probably
where you know, most traders would have
got out, you know, at least lighten up
their position. Now, again, let's talk
about the delta here, okay? So,
this time it it's it's a little bit
different, okay? So, here you've got the
delta, you're coming down into the lows,
okay? And what's taking place in the
delta is it's also getting weaker right
here.
-386, -337, -220, -63.
And then it turns positive, 101, -81,
+216, my uh then 54, -31,
32, 33 before it starts getting bigger
here, 172, 158.
All right, then it really starts growing
here, 39, 193, uh 209, 331, 300, 309 in
here where it becomes consistently
strong, but
you have the selling into the low that's
decreasing, -386, -337, -220, -63.
Okay? That's what I just showed you
happened this morning, right? You're
coming down into a low area, in this
case towards the low of the day. Uh this
morning was coming down into a swing
low.
And the aggressive selling is there, but
it's getting weaker. It's it's not as
strong on the way down, and and once we
know that,
the aggressive selling has weakened,
we're starting to get a sense that
the aggressive sellers are getting
tired, right? They don't necessarily
want to sell so much. And then you sort
of go then you go sideways in here,
right? We go sideways
all through here, and look at these
deltas, right? They're they're small.
54, 31,
32, 33. And
when you have small deltas, right? It's
basically telling you
that buying and selling, the aggressive
buying and the aggressive selling is
evenly matched, right? Because not no
one side is clearly dominating. You
know, we had the positive 216. Okay,
that's good.
Right? Maybe this market could have
rallied, you know, you had positive 101,
but the market was sort of struggling to
rally. Why? It's because there was still
some selling that needed to be done,
right? That's why this next bar, you
know, is that red bar down. Right? It
started to go up two or three ticks, and
then boom,
red bar down. But even though as it came
down, right? The buying and selling was
evenly matched. You know, what was
interesting here is even though you got
the delta of 54,
the volume
is 2728,
okay?
So, what's that telling you, right? It's
our heaviest volume out of any of these
bars. The next highest volume here is uh
2698. So, this is this is the strongest.
26 98, we had a delta of minus 386, but
now you got a very, you know, a heavy
volume bar, 2728, but the volume is only
54. So, I know the buying and selling is
evenly matched. And when I have small
delta numbers, usually around 50 and
less, you know,
it could be positive or negative based
on one trade. You know, this is a
1-minute chart. So, you know, maybe the
the bar had to close because 1 minute
was up. That's why when I'm looking at
smallest deltas,
you know, it's kind of, in a sense,
neutral
because no one side is in control. So,
when no one side is in control, again,
we're we're at our low, and we got very
small positive delta, right?
Why we at our low?
What's going to cause us to go to our
low? Is aggressive selling. So,
even though we got smallest delta, that
I know that there's decent buying taking
place. Okay? Is it a sign of absorption?
Well, we have this right here. We got a
prominent point of control. Here we have
another prominent point of control,
which is a sign of absorption. So, I
know that we're coming down into the low
and we're running into absorption. We're
running into the aggressive selling
weakening as we saw in the delta here.
And again, why don't we have big
negative deltas coming in here? We
don't. We got small ones. 81, -81, -31.
But, really the French kiss right here,
this one contract trades, right? It's
very visual. You could see that the one
contract trades, you know there's
exhaustion.
And then what happens? Boom. The market
rallies a quick 10 points in about
less than 10 minutes. Okay? And then you
you saw it even went up higher. So,
that's the order flow exhaustion entry
model, right? You're You're looking for
exhaustion following signs of absorption
coming in at a level. Today had a great
example. Yesterday had a few great
examples. We'll see you what the rest of
today's trading
um can give you guys. So, thanks for
watching this video and I'll see you on
the next one.